during its third apex legends death
stream respawn gave us our first look at
what's coming in apex legend season 4
we're gonna get juiced up on whatever
that stuff is that octane is taking and
speed through everything you need to
know let's go for a ride the new season
is called assimilation it kicks off on
February 4th which is the birthday of
apex legend a new Legend weapon and a
revamped rank mode will be making their
way into the game we thought we were
going to get a look at a new character
called revenant after a bunch of teases
from respawn by instead the studio did a
slick little slide and popped up with
Forge an ex MMA fighter joining the apex
games under the sponsorship of Hammond
robotics if you remember Hammond
robotics is one of the major
corporations that partnered with the IMC
aka the bad guys in the titanfall series
so he might be a bit of a bad boy we
still don't know much about how he plays
but based on his design he seems to look
like an offensive character that arm is
made for her in baby also outing the
season 4 is a new sniper rifle The
Sentinel similar to the charged rifle
the Sentinel is a bolt-action rifle
focused around a charging mechanic
instead of needing to charge in order to
fire The Sentinel seems to be a gun that
can charge itself to fire a more
powerful shot allowing you to snipe a
force with a fast but weak shot or
strong but slow on respawn is changing
how assets work in simulation the timer
for getting an assist will be extended
from 5 seconds to 7.5 seconds giving you
a higher chance to earn points by
helping a teammate down an opponent
season 4 will also allow you to earn
assists points when an ally kills an
enemy you tricked with a mirage decoy
nabbed with a pathfinder grapple damage
with a crypto EMP or scan with a crypto
or bloodhound teamwork makes the assist
stream work Kings Canyon is returning to
apex legends in season 4 though you'll
have to wait a bit of time before you
can play on it again assimilations
ranked mode will now be divided into two
hearts the first of which will see you
continued to play on wards edge from
February 3rd to March 23rd the latter
half will take players back to King's
Canyon from March 24th to May 5th in
rank mode the tiers have been adjusted
so their levels that were once
considered apex predator and now code
master the rank of apex predator will
only be given to the 500 best players on
each platform so only 1500 people in the
world
hold the prestigious rank there you go
season four looks to be jam-packed with
new content and now you've got
everything you need to know to keep
scoot in menlo in amigo
[Music]